in february this year
the intergovernmental agreement for
non-visa travels
entered into force and this is indeed
going to facilitate connections
across the board it's going to
facilitate
cultural exchanges support activities
even more so that next year carter will
be hosting
the world cup competition
as for our global agenda we discuss
syria and our views here are similar
the 2254 resolution of the young
security council should be fulfilled in
full
we briefed our colleagues on the steps
which we take
as part of the astana format which
brings together russia
iran and turkey and we also briefed our
colleagues on
how the geneva platform is operating as
you know the
constitutional committee and its draft
commission are working
actively its previous session was
completed on the 4th of december and i
believe that
the results of that session were quite
promising
i'm being carefully optimistic here and
the next meeting which is to take place
in january second part of january will
be a more detailed meeting when the
participants of these bodies will start
working on the constitution per se
foreign
um
our positions are similar we need to
step up our efforts in order to create
the environment for a lasting political
process
a lot of initiatives has been put
forward
and what is important is to coordinate
every effort
and work under the hospice of the united
nations
we are very much aligned by this
protracted pause
with signing a special envoy for libya
foreign
we agreed that seeking
a position on how the israel and the
country and other countries are
normalizing relations the issue of the
palestine should not be overlooked this
issue should be resolved in full
compliance with the
arab peace initiative with the yuan
resolutions
and we also confirmed that russia and
qatar
want to restore the palestinian unity as
soon as possible
that's what we want to see and we want
to see the process between the heart and
hummus
to come back to where they used to be
again
we discuss the situation in the gulf
region we believe it is critically
important to continue pushing
for unity unity over a process that
can and should lead to a lasting
resilience system for collective
security in this very important region
all in all these talks have been very
useful and meaningful for us and i'm
grateful
to our friends from qatar for their
cooperation
we agreed on some concrete steps to be
taken to
reinforce the consultation mechanisms we
have
between our ministries
now i'm sincerely grateful to my second
number for
our close cooperation and now i
give the floor to his excellency the
minister of qatar
foreign
thank you very much to your friend sergi
lavrov the foreign minister of
friendly russian federation first of all
i would like to thank
for the warm welcome that we have
received here
and our baiting of today is the
innovation of my context while my stay
my visit in russia yesterday i had a
chance to meet my russian counterparts
from the russian
iteration government
also i had meetings and a number of
economical
agencies all these contexts are aimed to
improve our bilateral
relations in a commercial sector
we highly appreciate the friendly
relations between russia and qatar
that are based on the implications taken
by the leaders of two countries
on increasing context and
improving the relations between the
countries
and uh with my counterpart sergio lavrov
we discussed our bilateral
relations and potential steps to deepen
uh our relations in all possible areas
including
trade and commercial and all other
possible
fields of our relations
and apart from the political matters we
discussed economical cooperation matters
uh
like increasing the turnovers to
correspond our expectations uh in
expectations of our leaders and
uh so that it corresponded
the level of our investment partnerships
as my friend sergey lavrov mentioned the
cooperation
in investment is done mostly by the
between the russian investment fund and
the qatar
investment authority is
one of the largest platforms but other
than that
we also have cooperation uh
within other structures and other
platforms
is one of the biggest ambassadors from
the
middle east region if we talk about
russia and we would like not only to
keep it at this level but to encrypt it
so that we could
open new opportunities for
investment and these matters were also
discussed during my visit to russia
i would like to thank uh russian
counterparts
for the invitation to take part in the
postponed saint petersburg
economic forum hopefully the
participation of qatar
will help to host the event
on a good level and to increase our
cooperation
in all fields
and we also appreciate the determined
determination of russia to cooperate
further uh for example
in a gas exporting platform uh
gas exporting countries platform and our
further
cooperation in this sector as well
and we also highly appreciate the
support comprehensive support from
russia
within the context of preparation for
hosting the world cup
fifa world cup that our country is going
to house in 2022
and because of this cooperation and
collaboration
we can learn from the experience that
russia had up
hosting this event back in 2018
we also want to strengthen our
cooperation
in culture and in other sectors
as for the political matters we talked
about
certain original matters
uh first of all we talked about the
developments
within the context of persian gulf
crisis
we also discussed that the safety and
security in the persian gulf
and the situation around the iranian
nuclear program
for qatar and we explained it to russia
the
safety issues in the region are
a priority
it is a no one interest to escalate the
situation we
are interested in holding and staying in
dialogue with all the countries
in the region and with iran
we are aware of uh
numerous diplomatic initiatives on
behalf of the friendly countries
in qatar we welcome all the initiatives
aimed at stabilizing the situation in
the region
and a search for the mutually beneficial
solutions to stabilize the situation
in the gulf we also talked about the
situation in syria
qatar reaffirmed
its desire to work under the
resolutions made by the u.n in
particular the religion
resolution number 2254 and
others
the settlement in syria is possible
without
reaching a fair and just political
solution so that this settlement and
solution
was fully adhered to the
desires of the syrian people
as for libya
when we talked about the situation there
we reaffirmed
our desire to work along the political
lines
and to support all the ceasefire
initiatives
we also reaffirm our adherence to the
resolution regarding libya made by the
security council of the un
and we also support the efforts
under the edges of the un on reaching
the just and fear
settlement in this country that would
correspond to the deeds
and wishes of the libyan peoples as for
the palestinian issue
in qatar we always advocate reaching
the fear solutions fair decisions in
regard of our brotherly palestinian
people based on the corresponding
international
decisions and resolutions
and it would not be impossible without
strictly adhering by israel to the
current
resolutions and
allowing the palestinian people to help
their state within the borders
as of 1967
and also under the condition that the
capital is going to be in the east
jerusalem and all the refugees should
get the right
to return to their homes
we welcome any constructive efforts in
this regard
and we think that arab peace initiative
is the tool
that is aimed at reaching the fear
resolution of this problem in the
interest of the palestinian people
we also discussed the matter of
the break inside the
stein and we think that both parties
should be
helped to reach the common ground
and to resolve and overcome all their
differences
and we have reached an agreement to
continue to
exchange the opinions on all the matters
of mutual interest
on the global arena and on the regional
arena
thank you very much mr ministry for
your hospitality the talks were fruitful
thank you very much good afternoon
and my second question for mr lavrov
new sanctions were introduced against a
large number of the russian enterprises
and companies
and against officials so what would be
the response of russia thank you
the first question is for mr eltani
what level are the efforts what stage
are the effort
on the specification of the countries
and the gulps and the contents
of the summit that is going to take
place on the 5th of
january and at riyadh are there any
difficulties or
any problems with that and what can we
expect from this event
as for the question regarding the
settlement has is between the countries
of the persian gulf but
two weeks ago we reached the victory i'm
talking about the statement by the
brotherly covet
a statement that defines the main
parameters
that the parties are going to reach
at the future summit and reaching
agreement among ourselves and we
are always positive towards such steps
and such
measures and we come from the position
that we
must reach unity within the our
persian countries and with the
preservation of the sovereignty of the
countries
that are members
of this council
and we have only positive expectations
regarding the upcoming discussions
counter is going to show the positive
attitude we hope to reach
a certain agreement that will put an end
to
the differences that we currently have
and we
are positive
that the differences that we have now
they are in no one's interest
and uh there are no winners with the
crisis that we're going through
currently
and i think that all the states in the
region are going to
win if we are going to have a positive
decision regarding this matter we will
restore trust in the region and trust to
this important
agency to this important platform which
is
uh crucial for the security in the
region
as for the possible
difficulties we see no political
difficulties and barriers maybe
there would be some other barriers but
we try to ignore them in doc and we try
to
keep the positive attitude uh to find
constructive
resolutions at the upcoming event
you asked about the new sanctions
imposed by the
us the sanctions are against
russian and chinese companies and
individuals the fact is it is that we
are not surprised
riaz has long been quite aggressive and
hostile towards russia
we will retalia and we will do that in a
mirrored way
we will respond in kind but we will also
be
you know drawing some conclusions that
this situation
and certainly this is going to take
impact on the
overall landscape of our relations with
the united states
these actions on the part of washington
reflect
the fact that the us is now
strategically
banned on undermining its competitors
in global markets it does it
by unfair competition directly violating
the rules and norms of the wto
once again we see that the us does not
care
about international law and it only
highlights
that the us will continue pushing for
imposing its own
rules on everyone else our european
partners say again and again
that there should be some rule-based
world order
i hope they understand what kind of game
they're playing
because well such things they might be
used against
any country on this planet
so we will take into account these
recent developments
and we will be
changing the way we approach our
business relations because the us has
proved to be an
unreliable partner and certainly these
recent developments are going to impact
the
relation between our countries overall
interestingly things which the us is
doing
backfires because the u.s businesses
suffer from that they're suffering
losses because of the political actions
recent context which took place as
part of the business council of russia
and the u.s
they show that most of the businessmen
are not satisfied with the
current situation and they would like to
see
the tendency to stop they want us to
come back to
normal relations based on seeking
benefit for both of us
thank you
mr lavrov hello the first question is so
how is the stabilization of the
situation the
settlement your counterpart was talking
about what kind of
impact it could have on the situation in
the gulf we heard a lot about the
russian initiative but on the other hand
the usa they sent new
troops into this region on monday we
heard about this
and you talked about the settlement
uh is it going to happen only in regard
of the saudi arabia or
other arab countries as well there are
four of them what about 13
points about that these countries were
given to you as requirements free
requirements
is this already something that has
already been done
or is it something that you're going to
discuss in
january during this summit
foreign
russia hopes that the
summit which is to take place on january
the 5th and will
be bringing together the gulf countries
will have to overcome
the existing differences of opinion in
the gulf cooperation council
and it will allow to well bring its
activities its operation back to normal
we are interested in seeing that happen
first and foremost because
all the countries of the gulf
cooperation council
are our partners and our friends
and we would like to see them
come into terms without any differences
or opinion
second that will bring unity
to the council the council will again be
operational in full
and that is important to implement the
plans and projects which are aimed
at ensuring greater security in the gulf
and one way to do that is through
cooperation with iran
our initiative is well known we have put
forward a number of interests actually
for many years we've been promoting a
conceptual framework for security
in this region a year ago we updated
this document
and everyone who can potentially be part
of the process
have this document already they're
familiar with it
uh
frankly we've seen a lot of interest
towards our initiative
last autumn we organized a
federation a conference
to bring together the experts of these
countries and
when we presided over the security
council we held a
an open door meeting with qatar and
others
dedicated to finding solution to this
very issue
we discussed the existing plans and
initiatives and of course there was some
disagreement
and yet it was a discussion it was
dialect
um
so we do hope that the summit
is going to take place and it will
yield tangible results
as for the question regarding the
of the fact that it is going to be
normalization with the saudi arabia or
with the other
states as well uh so we managed to
hold the meeting between our countries
and saudi arabia we also had context
with the united states of america
but saudi arabia during this context
during these talks
always talked on behalf of all the
countries in this
in our region
and from our side
we have a positive estimation
of all the discussions we think it is
aimed at fighting the unity
within all the gulf countries called
states so
that we could provide the security and
safety
in our region and among all the gulf
states
and of course we emphasized uh
our attention our attention to the
important elements to
respect the sovereignty of the country's
non-interference in the internal matters
and the respect for the decisions made
by the
member states
we think that no one has right
no tattered not any other countries
uh have the right to force any
conditions
we are convinced that everyone must act
based on the common goals that we have
which is a creation of the mutual trust
of the trustful
atmosphere so that we could
build a full functioning structures and
for function
cooperation thank you
thank you
uh
huh
you